foreign
[Music]
ER nerdy news you need to know right
here live from our very own breakthrough
Tommy getting the guns out come on hello
uh yeah we're here in our break room
where we normally have breaks and eat
snacks and drink sodi pops but not now
not today not during this hour because
it's time for the break room and coming
up on the show today Lord of the Rings
The Two episodes at once that was a
rough one it didn't work as well uh I've
seen Lulu post a thirst trap but it's
not what you'd expect and we are getting
more and more pumps for the uh premiere
of She-Hulk Attorneys
at the very same time two two rings at
the same time it was possible impossible
you know if I had all the money in the
world that's what I'd paid for yeah two
Lord of the Rings at once yeah that's
right we can make it happen we can make
it happen yeah who's gonna make it
happen well we have Erica who's on the
show today
[Applause]
hello oh beautiful doing scales and next
to him we got Jessica Clemens oh rump
and finally sitting next to me the
always uh legal Tommy Bechtel that's
right not guilty don't trust the media
Gucci to moochie and contribute to my
legal defense fund uh please don't
contribute to his legal defense funds
yeah he keeps off that money he keeps
all that money
legal defense if you want to throw away
some money today our super chats are
open and for every hundred dollars we're
honking out that's right in honor of
She-Hulk uh we have some random Topics
in the jar here that's right hot topics
for every time we cross the hundred
dollars someone is gonna Hulk out and
they'll Hulk out on this random topic uh
and you'll get to see their angry side
and guess what you wouldn't like them
when they're angry also join our Discord
if you're 18 years and older go on our
Discord uh you can have lots of
conversations there you can submit clips
of the week you can send in voicemails
you can do all sorts of fun stuff stuff
uh so do that and also if you're still
watching hit that like button oh you did
it thank you we got Terrapin fans in the
chat loving that shirt all right okay
got the Terps out there a lot of Gary
Marshall for Gary Williams who was the
loser basketball coach uh Gary Williams
Gary Williams I like that guy yeah good
guy still got us a chip in 2002. win me
a lot of money gambling legal if you
know the right people baby your trash
bags trash bags know about that they do
know about that and you know what else
they know about headlines
oh my gosh the first two episodes of
Lord of the Rings the rings of Power are
gonna release on September 1st at 9 00
PM Eastern now September 1st is a
Thursday but that's that's the weekend
before Labor Day so that's not Labor Day
weekend they want that long tail release
schedule you know what I mean uh so then
after those first two episodes uh the
episodes will come out one at a time the
subsequent weeks but on Fridays at 12
a.m Eastern uh 9 p.m Pacific uh
emergency forever PM wherever you live
or a.m I don't know how the world works
but yeah we get two for one at the
beginning so it'd be a nice way to kick
off Labor Day weekend uh next headline
was joking around about uh The Avengers
facing Jonathan Majors as king and he
posted a little image to his Twitter
let's take a look at that oh yeah maybe
I can't read that at home uh Stephen
Lewis said bro The Avengers are straight
up effed wow
you're not asked baby you're only asked
if you don't accept their invitation to
come on the break room yeah
tell SEMA we got his back tell him where
team seemu we see you see moo come on
the break room tweet at him nicely don't
threaten him guys don't we don't want to
fight him don't threaten we want to talk
to him talk to him about the Barbie
movie talk about bulking up to fight
Jonathan Majors whatever we need yeah
yeah tell Samu to come kick it with us
yeah Chrissy in the chat break me in
half
that is not him filming anything for uh
Marvel we should say yeah that was him
on the set of Creed Three can't wait for
that one that man is not eating bread at
all right now no no
that morning yeah he's not even thinking
about me yeah yeah uh but please simu
come on the break room see me see you
you know what I mean all right next
headline uh Zoe Saldana she posted a a
bunch of selfies a little real I don't
know what the kids call it these days my
Instagram a montage uh if you're a
cinematic if you're a cinephile wait
what is it there is there is a a phrase
when the a fan cam right when it's like
a bunch of images that fans make of
someone like that oh no it was it was
she made it I know you can be a fan of
yourself like K-pop stands we'll do like
fan cams of like uh BTS and uh blackpink
and I run out of K-pop names that I know
that was two more than I know
well there are a bunch of it is a bunch
of shots of her from the summer I guess
she was kind of talking about summer
it's that angle you have when you first
open your phone and you're looking down
it's very strange but one of them was
her as Gamora in her ravagers outfit
excuse me
now we did get a little hint from
Comic-Con from the people who saw it in
the kind of leaked description of the
clips that she appears to be the leader
of the ravagers now or have some form of
ownership over the ravagers which kind
of makes sense because they don't have
yondu right and she's a badass
Sean Gunn's characteristics
he's joined the guardian so uh it makes
sense and I kind of like that idea of
yeah her taking over the ravagers uh
Peter Quill's adopted family or original
adopted family and kind of like he wants
to be with her and he wants to be with
that one she's as angry as what she did
we saw our last as it seems like the
ravages would be better for her then
yeah you know well and it would be funny
she's kind of made them a menace again
you know like they were doing bad stuff
absolutely they still have gentlemen
like taser face high in the Rings that's
problematic I want well teacher face got
killed he goes eventually guys
eventually yeah my favorite my hopeful
part of this is that uh she's horrible
they're like oh we got gotta go talk to
Gamora
yeah yeah but they get captured or maybe
they come the rappers just come and get
quiller and like you got to get her out
of here so knock something back into her
we're not having fun anymore
um today or not even today it was I
think I made it came yesterday we got an
interview with Mark Ruffalo where he
mentions there's a chance for us to get
World War hulks
let's actually look at the clip though
let me look at the clip there's a few
Easter eggs in this thing that kind of
led us down to believe the the world war
Hulk storyline are you up for a solo
Hulk movie
anytime they want to do it I'm here
all right
um all right last but not least I'll let
you get out of here
um Kevin has obviously revealed that all
this is going to kind of event and end
an Avengers secret War
um how do you think this will compare to
end game what do you what do you think
what can you tell us what can you tease
us with well it's going to be hard to
top end game but um if I know Kevin and
I know marvel it's gonna be pretty
amazing it'll be a big bang yeah we'll
go out with a big bang
is that interview like on a cherry
picker or is it right I don't understand
why there's so much time
maybe that happens
at Game of Thrones we were like whoa
Matt Smith is actually really short just
so you guys know I don't I'm not gonna
say I don't want him to fight me I I
want him to rest
he'll just go at your ankles don't you
worry about it yeah
I like I think that was a an adorable
clip that was a cute that was I that was
I like the little look Mark gave to the
camera
I mean it's tough to interview with
people on the red carpet you like going
on but a yes or no question is not a
good leader I was like what else was he
supposed to state right no I would not
like to do it thank you so much I'm also
sure Mark Ruffalo loves the Hulk but I
also don't think he knows what world war
Hulk is or the storyline so I think
would ask like oh World War Hulk do you
think you're gonna get a solo film you
don't think we're okay like solo film
yeah I'll do whatever they want me to do
so that like 10 minutes 10 million
dollars
but as we do know his fans and how we
also have been yelling at least I have
uh Thor Ragnarok didn't really give us
the full storyline of Hulk that I wanted
I want a whole movie so
um we're hoping that maybe he will get a
solo film and maybe it will be World War
Hulk for those people that don't know
World War Hulk was basically after
Planet Hulk where uh the uh Illuminati
sent him uh off Planet because he was
too Reckless and they didn't know how to
handle it and then he went through a
hole ended up on zakar and took over
sakar with a bunch of people but a ship
blew up killing half the people on that
planet he was like we're going back to
Earth we're gonna take it down he kills
literally almost everybody he runs
through everybody he runs through
everybody he turns Madison Square Garden
into like a Arena like and freaking uh
Coliseum yeah
and Gladiator he makes everyone fighting
he makes everybody fight and the only
person he doesn't fight and he's okay
with his name more because Neymar was
the only person on the Illuminati that
was like we shouldn't just banished him
yeah
um and then also the storyline with uh
comes with uh SCAR or his son because he
when he was banished Jessica his son's
name is scar you can't trust a man named
Scott don't try to get back on me Scott
[Laughter]
turn your back on me
here
so he has a son also the next Vengeance
later on and so the storyline is so big
and so Hefty I would love to get that
storyline do we think
um that this would happen in any like do
we think this would happen I love it
because it makes perfect sense to me you
can't do a solo Hulk movie about him
just being Bruce Banner and the
struggles of the emotional the burden
that turning into the Hulk takes on him
we also know he's now able to become
smart Hulk or Professor Hulk so there
are levels to this talk send him to
space it's got to be no it's got it's
got to be Intergalactic baby yeah it's
gotta be here do you think he's gonna
but like in World War Hulk he's so angry
and I don't know if we're gonna get that
angry of a Hulk again that was kind of
what we got in Thor Ragnar listen we
this is what's happening all of our
original Avengers that are still alive
are getting pissed because the world's
changing people are changing the climate
is changing you know you can't get
around away with all the locker room
talk you used to do maybe once in a
while you know he'd slaps Scarlet witch
on the behind and it would be fine it's
a different world now that's not okay
this is just how I want the break room
to be but we're not allowed to do it uh
so anyway yeah I know I don't think all
of that I do think uh like the the older
older Avengers are kind of getting
pushed to the side for these new hot
young Heroes and not really but you know
what I mean like literally in the movies
and so like yeah I do believe that some
of them can become jaded as their
friends die off or sacrifice themselves
you know you start to that's Gotta Wear
on you you lost his lady he lost his
best friend his other best friend turned
into an old man
ran for president is now currently our
president I think there's there's a lot
of people in on the internet who will
complain about uh MCU Hulk because he's
always nerfed right yeah he's never this
like Unstoppable Force even though in
the comics plenty of times they find a
way to stop him they find a way to stop
him but he's Unstoppable yeah
it's raging within Age of Ultron and he
was under a spell at that point right uh
he's always kind of been this manageable
thing that can be beaten and stopped by
different forces I think taking him off
the planet you you give him a reason to
become full Hulk Unstoppable again where
he can destroy another planet I would
what I would like to see because there
is a lot in World War Hulk and if they
really are going to do Secret Wars I
don't think they would do the same world
war Hulk where you're making Heroes
battle each other it's kind of similar
but I do like the idea of some of the
world war Hulk story especially him
having a kid on that planet if you
remember what he was in Ragnarok and
Bruce Banner comes back he doesn't know
where he's been yeah yeah yeah and I
think no with his uh bgd cucumbers in
the chat for the bgd
cucumbers in the chat broccoli in the
chat uh Hulk was um messing around with
a woman who could handle the Hulk and
maybe she's pregnant uh and he's gonna
have to deal with that so this is my
this is my situation with that I agree
with scar coming in because I think
think we're getting into a phase now
where all of the Avengers are having
children because they're all Africans
they're all having kids they're getting
older and also this is a reduced reused
recycle you guys are making
it isn't going to be this car we see in
the comic books and I'm so sorry because
scar on the comic books is a menace and
I love him he's so strong and he's so
hot but like yeah I love that right hair
and a bulk man so like it's really
attractive but um
I think they're gonna Nerf Scar and make
him hulkling I don't think we're gonna
get like a scroll I think they would
just use scar because I think in the
comic scar it took a year for him to get
to like that big ass thing that we see
now so I think in the Marvel they're
like why don't we just have him be the
actual hulkling uh I know that sounds a
little too wild and too ridiculous but I
think it's like if you're gonna bring
scar in and I do want him to have a kid
I just think he's gonna have a kid in
She-Hulk I think he's gonna go back to
sakar and She-Hulk that's what that ship
was there it's gonna pick him up take
him to sakar and that's where he's gonna
find a new love interest now that
Natasha's dead okay and that's where
he's gonna and that takes him out of the
narrative most of She-Hulk so that
She-Hulk
I like it so I think that's where scar
is going to come in and then maybe they
can just make scar part of the Young
Avengers maybe not even as hulkling but
like you know how hulkling is called
Hulk Lane it'd be weird to have scar
who's actually so then at the end of
this season of She-Hulk you're gonna
have to throw an auntie on there because
she's gonna be auntie
so yeah now that Natasha's dead we're
gonna get a new romance kind of sort of
thing going on uh do we think that like
how I said do we think that we could see
this starting in She-Hulk
[Applause]
let me add a second question on to this
do we think it could start in She-Hulk
and when I want to hear both all three
of you guys argument yes or no She-Hulk
and then in what phase would it come in
oh like if there was a World War Hulk
movie yeah a whole movie where does it
fit in yeah we got one more Hulk or any
other Solo movie where would it fit in
the phases and do you think it would
start in She-Hulk I think they could lay
some eggs
I don't know how a Hulk is born Lisa
Banks you could start planting the seeds
right uh and I do think this is a good
way to get Hulk off the planet for Kang
because if they're they're kind of
moving some of our higher powered
players off the chessboard right uh
Scarlet Witch is missing I'm dead red
mask uh uh uh um Supreme Doctor Strange
he's gone off to the dark dimension with
some chick he just met 100. you got to
do it all right but if you made a
strange woman she has to go to the dark
dimension
and now Hulk who's our other like super
strong character get him out in space
off of Earth and so yeah where are the
Avengers who's Who's Gonna Save earth
when ten comes a call 100 yes I like
both of those okay what's your idea yeah
I could see
um that ship that we see in the trailer
taking Hulk uh him disappearing for a
couple of episodes him coming back being
kind of like this discombobulated and
then in the finale of She-Hulk I could
see that ship returning uh a very nice
sicarian lady coming off the ship and
going
it's time for you to meet your son and
then
She-Hulk will return you know I uh I
pitched at first that Zakarian ship was
uh someone to serve a subpoena for him
an illegitimate child just taking a
sample of him yeah
be representing yeah
what do you think yes yeah I I like that
idea too I was going to say that would
be a good excuse to take him off Planet
but then
we so that ship kind of appears what it
looks like when they get into that car
accident like that's the thing that kind
of causes the car accident but then we
see footage of uh Hulk and She-Hulk
training and having their Mantra so that
had to be after the ship thing so I
don't know if maybe the ship appears car
accident she gets her powers but she's
recuperating in the hospital and while
she's you know recuperating becoming
She-Hulk he goes off planet and maybe
scar is already born yeah and baby mom
was on the ship like while your cousin's
healing up we gotta go back to the car
and you gotta handle business and then
after he's like all right I've been a
dad for like three weeks you ready for
this whole class yeah and that's how
that happens training begins now maybe
they the mother names him Scar and then
Bruce is like no no it's a little
honkling and then they're like
let's just call it skull clean now when
is Betsy Ross going to come back
Tyler we need her back
foreign
[Music]
Thunder uh Iron Man already had a kid
pep has a daughter
um
Bishop but um uh Ant-Man has a daughter
yeah so it's like all of them are having
children might as well hold give him one
now and I think I think we could see
that but I think saying World War Hulk
is gonna happen is really hard because
of the fact of like he's such a villain
in that and I think we would have got
that in thought Ragnarok versus what we
have now because the Thor Ragnarok he
had he was like blinded by anger just
period yeah and in this I think it's
gonna be smart hold going back to sakar
being like people like me here I'm
studying it here I like it here as well
and like logically knowing that it makes
sense they're certainly not afraid to
take a title of a popular comic Saga and
and use that as a jumping off point so I
think we can kind of have a little bit
of both you know we can have the some of
the bones from World War Hulk with maybe
a little bit less of the uh nihilistic
anger and uh and destruction of his
enemies uh that are that are kind of
good guys in our world maybe Focus the
energy on the villains of our world oh
yeah people in the chat wanting Maury
Povich to get involved
Chrissy said at a Super Chat that's uh
somehow related to this do you think
Bruce watched the planets and stars go
by when he was heated into the bifrost
by Heimdall uh using hope fund and
infinity War remember and
if so how did he nerd vomit or how do
they not vomit all over Tony after he
landed uh that would make me very
nauseous but I think the Hulk is is able
to not vomit
I think his stomach is changing
indestructible yeah yeah because he
heals and stuff and like Bruce Banners
tried to not in the MCU but like try to
shoot himself but then the MCU oh that's
right so like
he's like the other guy so yeah I don't
know yeah he probably he probably
bifrosted as Hulk and when he landed he
started yeah
okay he's coming and also back to the
point of will there be a uh World War
Hulk movie I say maybe because there's
still a lot of blank spots in phase six
yeah so all we know is the two Avengers
movies and then fantastic it just seems
so yeah so here's phase six we got the
Fantastic Four The Avengers uh and then
we have Secret Wars Avengers Secret Wars
uh the second one is Avengers uh Dynasty
kids two of those are the worst part one
in our Moors
my biggest fear of this which I don't
think we ever will be out of Hulk but do
you think it'd be too late by phase six
to even introduce something like that no
nah slim knot we're always going to be
interested in it and it's time to give
you know I think Hulk has been a tough
character to give a solo movie and if
they can find a way to do it good Sunday
night it would be a good idea I think
the scar I think the scar and sakar
storyline is one that they should
absolutely follow through with them do
we all want them someone in the chat was
also like oh hope clean ain't even a
Hulk give me Scar and 100 I want uh my
biggest irritation and I hope they
address this and She-Hulk is like her
name is She-Hulk yeah
said they do what she she was
interviewed by Colbert yeah in my show
so yeah so they go over it it's the same
with whole Colleen it's like I want to
discuss that you guys just named him
that because he's green I think Hulk is
timely I mean he's on that Mount
Rushmore of Marvel Superheroes right
it's like Spider-Man Hulk probably
Wolverine and then uh let's say chatter
star from the yeah yeah I didn't name
any female uh Heroes
came out someone uh someone in the chat
this is just me to the person in the
chat that said bdg Brian David Gilbert
is watching I forgot and I love Brian
he's my friend and I feel horrible if
he's watching Brian David Gilbert you're
very popular and popular with bdgs
a World War Hulk could also if they you
know finesse and finagle it right could
be Mark Ruffalo and Hulk's uh Logan yeah
that's the thing and that's the thing
when Scar comes to Earth he beats the
crap out of Hulk he's like uh and then
they're fighting and he realizes you're
not the Hulk from like uh World War Hulk
here just this normal guy
uh we asked the chat do you think
She-Hulk will lay the groundwork for
World War hog 61 saying yes and where
would world war hokkada is so hard to
say be in the MCU phases most of you
agree in phase six I almost half of you
agree and it makes the most sense they
haven't really I don't think they got
time to stick it in there for uh face
fiber it might be a little tough Tanisha
Tanisha putting us over oh baby
while we're waiting to see who wins that
poll let's talk about the epic hero
shots one question really oh yeah really
quick uh Incredible Hulk Edward nortens
is allowed to be in the MCU in his MCU
by Eric bana's 2003
I'll watch a clip of that I haven't seen
that in a while
and like they take it up into space to
make them pass out it's like that
wouldn't happen that wouldn't happen
there's some interesting things in that
only Hulk you know 2003 wild time for
superhero movies we hadn't really found
our way no there's some fun stuff in
there but there is some weird stuff
there's some great directorial stuff on
the online Hulk he really tries to make
it visually look like a comic book with
some interesting cuts and things like
that but thought it's it's slow and
plotting and very strange and there's
Hulk dogs I don't want to get in touch
dogs
oh give it to me baby we want to thank
our we want to shout out our merch
friends over at the epic hero shop they
just released their green Justice merch
line inspired by She-Hulk aren't we all
a little inspired by She-Hulk yes these
days it's got several different t-shirt
designs including the newest limited
edition latest Obsession shirt Lady
Justice now wouldn't you buy one of
those shirts you unlock the chance to
give uh the opportunity to give a custom
shout out read by one of our inside
Marvel hosts or maybe even our own
Jessica Clemens
on one of our uh She-Hulk themed uh
programs on the channel they're also
gonna drop some uh some clothes inspired
by house of the dragon and or in rings
of power in the coming weeks so you know
you want to wear a shirt want to wear a
nice uh a nice shrink that feels good on
the skin and and uh good when you sin
head over to the epic hero merch shop
all right yeah that's a good way to
support the channel and we are gonna
Jessica's doing our hope breakdown today
that's a great way get pumped get pumped
uh yeah we're gonna have lots of Shield
coverage on the channel
um so get excited for that well uh I
guess I'm gonna Hulk out here before we
get to a segment Mike did you get the
mic it's by the Viking helmet give me
the mic okay this is give me the mic
Scott Steiner give me the microphone oh
boy I blew my voice already all right it
says Hulk out on any movie on any movie
very open-ended yeah
Hulk cry at League of zero
hope told there's no crying in baseball
but there is crying at the AMC Webster
12 where Hulk cried whole time Hulk cry
when sisters he reunite hope cry when
sisters fight Hulk cry when wounded
husband returned home from war
Hulk cry when the racing peaches lose
hopeless when Tom Hanks takes 45 seconds
piss
Hulk laugh at cameos from Gary Marshall
and Penny Marshall Hulk feel good about
Madonna in movie League of Their Own
yeah she played all the way with me oh
love all the way me
thank you beautiful it's great that was
a good apologies to the top of his voice
and to the blown out microphone if you
want to see anyone else do that we're
only
76 dollars away from our next home but
Tommy's still back in the pool though
that's fine I'll hold back again it will
be coughing blood
I don't I ain't got nobody to talk to
after this you want me to honk out again
hit me again you keep me in that pull
all night but you know what it's time
for a segment that feels right oh no
it's time for mandatory
that's right the segment's so lit that
yesterday we skipped it
we did skipping us hit my graphic
right the segment so electric that we
play that interview of short little Mark
Ruffalo on the red carpet again hit the
interview
there's a few Easter eggs in this thing
that kind of led us down to believe the
the world war Hulk storyline
oh that's right that's how they filmed
the Lord of the Rings
the segment that's so whack that we play
the picture of Jonathan Majors looking
Super Chat get the picture and leave it
up
right there
holy cow all right it's time for
mandatory fun now everybody
I wish we could put our heads on this
body like a little I could Photoshop
that for you guys oh thank you all right
all right that segment
that has gone on it's time for what
feels like Jonathan to take it off take
it off John is distracted by this
Jonathan the segment that feels like
it's been going on for a millennium
plays the set the graphic for thirsty
that's being no you don't have that
problem no no no no
yeah
what are they thirsty for tomorrow's
like please get to the second discussion
point today we're fine and a half left
all right now
Tom Holland absolutely devastated the
internet with uh with the news that he
was taking a break oh my God the money's
pouring him
social media but fear not
we here at the break room are Intrepid
and we have been hired to ghostwrite
some social media posts for Tom Holland
that's right these Spider-Man is off the
internet but we've created a little
writer's room here and if we don't do a
good job it's going to be a writer's
tomb because we're all going to be
locked in here so let's start before
let's start with the obvious
let's start with the obvious here
Twitter let's all pitch some tweets to
post from Tom's social Brandon you got
one for us yeah I got a couple addressed
these are just these are drafts these
are evergreen for you Tom yeah yeah no
problem have it is he British yes yes
haven't gotten a residual check in
several days did chaos walking ever come
out yeah I don't know yes uh here's
another one loving hacks on HBO Max can
I audition for season three I can do 14
backflips in a row wow
all right I got one more go ahead no
please uh is it
okay this is from Tom Holland this is
from Tom Holland not from me okay yeah
Zendaya's out of town and it's got me
bricked up heading to the gym yeah in
the suit
what does ripped up mean in British
language I think it means uh you can't
go to the lift because there's too many
bricks in the queue
that makes more sense now okay that
sounded like bricked up yeah
Zendaya today is our time so he can't go
to the WC they take care of himself she
gives him permission to go to the WC
that makes sense
she's like go Webb she's like go in
there and web all right I got one uh you
know Tom's pretty famous for not keeping
a tight lip on plot lines wow just got
the script for Spider-Man 4. can't
believe I get to Raw Dog Venom
yeah
Tom all right hey Tom Holland not me now
if you are if you're Venom
don't you automatically have like some
sort of uh prophylactic on the the oh
yeah
that's for the viewer to decide Jessica
you got something yeah um I was gonna uh
write one that was like uh uh webs do
come out of my butt sometimes uh I think
that's a funny one I think that's great
for him to post people over interact
also one that just says um who's Zendaya
I have a question for you when is it
yeah uh a what when when yeah yeah with
the when is Zendaya all right
this is riveting content
is more of like a writer's tomb yeah
just like a writer's Doom go ahead all
right I'm pretend I'm him okay oh yeah
yeah I like to act out my my best
British impression uh going to visit the
the execs at Marvel today hope I don't
spoil anything hashtag Gamora Takes Over
The Infinity Gauntlet oh
yeah
[Applause]
all right speed round before we end this
insanity and what has been the most
electric mandatory fun
how dare you date I want you to pick any
other social media platform and uh and
give us a Tom Holland post a Tom Holland
post on different social media that's
right uh uh it's gonna well he's gonna
be on Pinterest and he's gonna make a
board and it's gonna say things I look
at when I'm bricked up okay wow and it's
gonna be I'm picking up a theme sexy
ladies and a couple like sexy fox ladies
yeah I mean that in a furry sense yeah
okay yeah some squirrel girl's in there
oh definitely some squirrel girls in
there yeah love it love it uh mine is a
venmo transaction to uh fuzzy Freddy's
fur Factory and and they it's for six
hundred thousand dollars and the memo
line is for unbricking this Old Brick
shed uh because he's getting some sick
very furry gear coming in and uh maybe
making a video of his own uh I think uh
his like old dad will be in charge of
and he's gonna be posting on his
Facebook but he's only gonna be posting
locations so he'll be like Wells Fargo
how do I change the batteries
just Googling Gmail you know what I mean
like about Google and Gmail yeah all
right mine is uh he's dug up an old
Tumblr page Whoa We like Tumblr here
just so you know thank you Tumblr yes
and then so it's just Gifts of him and
Zendaya sharing flirty glances at each
other on pressure
oh adorable
and last but not least obviously on
LinkedIn oh yeah there's a post from a
Tom H that says expert Tumblr and
thespian seeks job in new franchise
after leaking information about raw
dogging Venom uh starting salary
negotiable resumes available uh on
request willing to do uh scenes of raw
doggedness great that's been mandatory
picture one last time oh yeah give us
the King give us the gang down see you
in green three
16 more dollars till the next rant don't
stop folks we can get there let someone
else Hawk out I wrote all these fun
health problems
get in there come on trash bags you can
do it it's Tuesday yeah we haven't
appreciated all the uh super chats we've
been getting from uh Fareed job ads
sending and UMD all day baby TV John's
John Adams saying Benedict Wong is
becoming the spiritual spiritual
successor to Stanley and Canada yes Wong
is up there on the Cameo
counts
always available I wish you paid by uh
Kublai Khan from uh from uh Marco Polo
on Netflix because he played the Kublai
Khan oh yes as like a variance yeah yeah
yeah I like that uh Charlie 836 pointing
out how Jessica's hair be popping yeah I
don't write him like just read them
folks hey by the way graveyard we see
your uh we see your Super Chat and your
frequent super chats and we appreciate
that can we get a Tom b23
100th episode we are going to have uh uh
atomicon like celebration with all of
our hosts oh yes yeah everybody's giving
and come back to Chicago baby I'll come
back to Chicago anytime you just got to
give us a reason for the season yeah
he's legally not allowed to come back
for three weeks but after the restroom
order is up yeah he's back in shy clean
up all my blood from that hotel room I'm
allowed to stand up first things Jesus
well It Ain't Easy Being Green folks and
this week is gonna get greener than ever
because She-Hulk will be premiering on
Disney plus we're super excited uh they
had their Premiere last night in
Hollywood I didn't get the invite I
don't know if it got lost in the mail or
what happened but the great thing is
we've gotten lots of fun news and sound
bites like tiny Mark Ruffalo speaking on
the the red carpet was it a green carpet
can anyone confirm uh was it a green
carpet I think it's purple purple okay
yeah uh but for getting lots of like
interviews and sound bites are coming
out now about what we're going to expect
from this show and in an interview this
week Tatiana maslani said that uh she
has a joke like Jen Walker's Jen Walters
would want to defend Wanda in court
saying she had quote had some tough
times uh that required quote a Nuance
defense again I I admittedly I'm not
like the biggest She-Hulk expert when it
comes to the comics but I do like that
what I'm learning about her is like
she's kind of like a better call Salt
boy yeah she's like totally willing to
defend uh morally ambiguous characters
she's she's there to help him out you
know what I mean uh and they were this
kind of came up in the interview that
because she's it looks like she's gonna
be defending Emil Blonsky she's not that
a prosecutor she's going to defend him
uh and this is a guy who attacked her
cousin
a lot of family yeah I'm messing up
Harlem supposedly no one died but if you
look at uh if you watch Daredevil the
cover said that hundreds of people died
I don't know you gotta you gotta do your
own research you gotta do your own
research
97 people died yeah yeah uh City thought
of a skank two people got hurt
um so that was like a funny thing she
said I don't think she would get to
defend Wanda but that would be very
interesting to see her do that uh one of
the She-Hulk directors Kat corio she
joked about wanting to bring JLo to the
MCU in the interview she actually
directed JLo and marry me uh that came
out on peacock uh that I was forced to
watch with my wife uh how do you like it
yeah I casually enjoyed it all right
I mean jail looks great yeah I added to
the MCU I say I think we need more
singers in the MCU we got Harry Styles
now we lost Lady Gaga to DC
she could double dip yeah I only have
Harry there's got to be another singer
right I mean
technically yeah exactly I don't think
if you're in as a civilian anymore
what's your name
Brie Larson's office
before she when she was like a teenager
like you know they tried to make her
like another Britney Spears she makes
music videos and everything you can
watch them on YouTube I Swear why would
you want to be Britney Spears it went so
well for her uh well no hiccups uh uh
Olivia Ann in the chat pointing out
Rihanna should be added to the Embassy
oh yeah I would be good in the MCU she
should play Mrs Bechtel yeah every
character that comes in and she should
fight Tom Holland for stealing her song
yeah
there was also an interview with Jessica
gal and uh cat corio where they
discussed kind of the metaphysical
ramifications of Jen Walters breaking
the fourth wall uh something that
Deadpool does but something we've seen
in Clips coming out uh the show uh quote
they talked about a lot saying quote uh
they discussed how much she should talk
to the camera is she talking is she
talking directly to the audience is
there another meta element is she
talking to somebody else that's more
behind the scenes I guess in like an
early draft of the script they had they
wanted to have like editors notes pop up
and then she could see them and comment
on them which I guess it's something
they do in the studio Comics show
comment I'm like yeah CDL at the writer
but I do appreciate that later they
didn't just have her breaking the fourth
wall as a joke it's like what does this
mean in the reality of this show so many
so many singers that we have forgotten
about Haley Steinfeld that's a pretty
popular singer
uh there was I forget sorry going up we
can't scroll up but there oh Jamie Foxx
obviously pretty good music career right
that's right uh and then there was
someone Jamie Foxx that grand followed
in that doesn't count okay no you've
been there for a while
no no he got grandfathered into the
emcee
Donald Glover Donald Glover
yeah
I want a kid I want a costume okay
yeah
and they did use his version of House of
the Rising Sun on the uh Umbrella
Academy that's true some strange reason
maybe the cheapest one to get no offense
to rent a runner come on the show we run
there bring your friends see Lulu on
this show actually everyone's Teemo
first Renner you can come if you're
available yeah oh uh Hulk rant Jessica
oh Jessica in the middle of our Hulk
discussion
Hulk out on social medic media
um
oh why do they have to put stories in
every app I'm so tired of it I don't
need a song when I'm going through
looking at pictures of your dorms I hate
it Twitter Instagram
Facebook
Snapchat no one needs stories and
Snapchat
what's next
venmo PayPal stories there's too many
stories and not enough books
yeah Hulk why is Instagram showing me so
many people I don't follow yeah oh Mark
Wahlberg
Mark Wahlberg oh my God
they're both scary looking
Punk why does why does Instagram want me
to poop so much yeah yeah why are they
so obsessed with me Tuesday on the
toilet long enough you'll buy more into
the Earth
[Applause]
uh and Avery penwell also something to
look forward to every day we're so happy
you're here and Bucky Barnes ATL trash
all day
I saw you cut a promo on me
I saw you cut a prom on me here's me
cutting run you great job I'm glad to be
here good promo yeah good promo hey guys
WWE Ross a lot better
[Applause]
he plays a character named pug he's like
another Warrior he's great he was on
Arrow where he was Aiden Chase oh yeah
Adrian Chase
vigilante they call the character the
Vigilante I think but he was revealed to
be uh working for
um foreign
and he's also on the other two anyways
he was on the red carpet uh normal sized
yeah and he gave a great little
interview about the backstory behind his
character uh which I I guess we have to
take his Cannon uh we have a clip of
that [ __ ] he is paying his way through
law school by being a bouncer at clubs
and one night he gets saved by
Spider-Man he gets jumped and he gets
saved so he decides to dedicate himself
to superhero law he wants to protect
superheroes that's who pug is you know
he's here and he's perfected his craft
best lawyer in the world and then he
gets to meet his hero She-Hulk let's go
I haven't seen the other two he's so
good on that show he's so funny yes he
is so great uh I love this and I I hope
he just did this on the red carpet and
now it's like Canon yeah
it's in the comics he was uh he was
paying for law school as a bouncer he
gets jumped by a bunch of people in the
alley and right before like the final
blow Spiderman ties them all up and he's
always like Spider-Man's the number one
and then he gets to defend Spiderman
please let me tell you how funny this is
really quick he gets a defense
Spider-Man and he's going against uh
Jameson and they're like you're gonna
get three million dollars Spider-Man's
gonna be great but then they bring in
Peter Parker and they're like you also
have to pay 3 million and then
Spider-Man says I'm gonna settle I'm
gonna settle
they said why and he was like don't
worry about it just settled
I'm so excited to see his character on
this show Brandon how about being
excited about the fact that trash bag
gave you twenty dollars to go see Rogue
one oh yeah
yo his sweet cheese it's good time boys
rotten Soldier uh I can't wait to go see
Rogue one and theaters again and see
them all die well isn't there a little
side piece they're gonna put out a rogue
one in theaters again in honor and or
coming out just a promoter
you said there was a piece about Andor
in it though right uh like then they
said they were doing like a little oh I
think they're gonna have like a little
clip yeah
many are speculating watching it on
Disney plus yeah yeah it is that is true
yeah and many are speculating it might
be the first five six minutes of the
episode well it's fun to see those
movies again
that real sound uh 4dx baby rocking the
chair spin water in your face
the purple or green or whatever color
carpet they had last night I wasn't
invited at the premiere it's okay yeah
uh Jamila Jamel was there looking
beautiful looking great I I don't think
I didn't tell John to pull a clip of
this unfortunately uh but she revealed
that Titania the character she's playing
is not gonna really be featured until
episodes five or six so if you're hoping
for Jamila Jamil early you're gonna have
to wait you gotta wait you gotta eat
your your vegetables
I think it's nine episodes nine episodes
she gets a little bit if you go back and
watch the trailers which I did I noticed
that she's in the background of almost
every shot oh really so there's like
like when she's we're like oh my gosh
your ass is so nice
so nice I've got a bit of an ass myself
it was quite a declaration okay it was
quite a declaration of ass dependence
yeah thank you
um
National Pleasures
the search for ask defendants oh my God
North Hollywood porn Community are you
listening
to help us let's make the valley sexy
again come on making a shirt make sure
we also heard from uh executive producer
uh cat corio uh she's also directed a
couple episodes I believe she addresses
the speculation of the Ghost Rider
appearance everyone has been kind of
thinking about her husband uh uh Rhys
corio actually plays the character
everyone was thinking but his name is
Donnie Blaze not Johnny Blaze I think we
have a clip of this one too uh well I
mean yeah he's a very powerful and
fantastic individual and he's amazing
and wonderful in every way
and uh you know he just lives to to a
maze and entertain but I feel like
there's more to it would you say that
the character there's more to that story
you know the only person who can
actually answer about his connection to
Ghost Rider is Kevin feige so we don't
know
yeah yeah
the bones are their money that's why
whenever I see that guy I think of
Entourage yeah yeah I think you should
leave uh you did see the carpet in the
background there was purple good job
yeah uh yeah she's she's the executive
producer of the show she also directs a
couple episodes but so it's not Johnny
Blaze we will not be seeing Ghost Rider
on this show but his character is called
Donnie Blaze which I think is very funny
and also defer to Kevin feige that's a
little cover your ass right there in the
MCU like it's up to him I feel like I'd
be so bad at answering questions
also you know man showed up in like a
polo shirt to the premiere I mean come
on yeah the poor women they dress up so
much and they get they do all the makeup
and the guys showing up here he knocked
it out of the park with Queens Boulevard
yeah but he followed it up with Medellin
and let's be honest that movie tanked
okay yeah couldn't be saved by anybody
they sold it for one dollar that was
awesome that was also probably a 500
polo shirt it looked very nice it was
definitely a penguin yeah
there was no Gildan folks
and respect the Gildan if you want to
sponsor us I'm wearing Gildan tits to
toes
oh
uh
Heaven show she revealed that and this
was kind of blowing our minds
Abomination we know he's going to be in
She-Hulk he was added to shanxi because
of his role in She-Hulk it wasn't the
other way around where they're like hey
She-Hulk you got to have Abomination
because we're putting it back in they
wanted to put Abomination into this show
and so they were like I think we need to
remind everybody who the H Abomination
is uh we have a clip of her talking
about that Abomination Emil Blonsky was
in my original pitch you know and at
that point like the last time we saw him
was in 2008 the Incredible Hulk I had no
idea what their relationship to this
character was anymore I don't know if
they had any plans but it was you know a
story I wanted to tell so I just put it
in there but you know because he was
built to built in to be such a big part
of the show uh in that original pitch
and in the writer's room you know we
really like
um you know we were creating this whole
story for him
um because everything in Marvel is
connected that was actually why he then
was put in chongqi because he was in our
show that a it was kind of to seed him
so that people can get excited but also
remember him and it kind of forced
people to go oh I should go back and
check in on him and remember who he is
and what all what all of that was about
I will do whatever it takes to write
what Jessica I want to work with her so
bad and let me tell you Jessica if
you're listening uh a lot of Jessica's
get a bad rep uh there's not a lot of
just a rabbit there wasn't a bad word I
was gonna say something Jessica Chastain
yeah I love Jessica I know but she gets
a bad word
she should be on a team together we can
write stories for Marvel together
Jessica and I even if you just need a
researcher I'm here for you please when
you're picking up Jeremy Renner please
grab Jessica gal on the way to the
studio
[Applause]
because I just want to remind we've got
just a few minutes yeah let's answer
some questions but if you want to hear a
Hulk out before we go 49 bucks away yeah
who will be the hero in the chat that
gets us to one more Hall cow today for
49 bucks away that's right I do I do
love it's got to feel so rewarding to be
like I was after you know I pitched this
thing to Marvel they like it and they
like it so much they're gonna affect a
whole other movie oh yeah I mean it was
very quick little thing with abomination
I think John Chi The Producers loved
having it because they put it in every
trailer that came out and we're like
come see this movie uh but I'm also so
happy that Abomination is back I love
Tim Rod uh I think he's great and we
know he's gonna get to be Tim Roth in
this too or not just always right right
right and I love this you know marvel
has the MCU has this like break break
glass in case of emergency of characters
that they can bring at certain times I
just love this payoff I think it's so
great I have a couple things really
quick I will say number one Alex Reese
and the chat said that I was thirsty
I mean I work with you Jessica I think
sometimes you're you're the first time
you were a uh
salty scribe yeah
secondly
it's gonna start wielding it like yeah a
little bit of spice also
um I think it was a great idea to put
him in chunchi because shenshi not until
the like post-credits ends with uh
please correct me if I'm wrong it didn't
have that many ties to the future of the
MCU what was going on abomination of
like out there we got to see that one
woman that is clearly a black like oh
that was a black widow there was a a
soldier that had the extremists yeah but
other than that if that entire scene
like didn't exist we wouldn't have had
like any like connection except for the
mid credit scene but I do think it's
very smart of Jessica to be like
no go ahead and put this in here and
we're gonna just ripple effect and also
give people time to research who he was
in case you forgot who was sure I like
it I second that I second that well it's
also because I always forget like even
our fans for
um uh from new rockstars a lot of them
are like 18 19. so they weren't even
here really for the 2000 well 2003
definitely not but 2008 the 2008 people
and it's not it's not on Disney plus uh
it might be now I forget I think I think
it's still on HBO because for a long
time it was always in a weird spot and
it was hard to find and a lot of people
love to skip it uh there's some great
stuff in it
yeah uh and it was of in the early MCU
it was one of the harder PG-13 movies
yeah for sure yeah it was a little more
Rough Around the Edges a little more
violent a little more sexy yeah lots of
fun times in that movie Charlie C and uh
TD Jones putting us over
um
for our own Eric and uh TD for the
roomies how about this we could do the
poll but why don't we pull a topic and
win all four of us send us out today on
the hall count we'll start over there
because he hasn't gone we're gonna go on
a hotel and before we leave we just want
to remind you guys uh join that Discord
we're still doing our clips of the world
yes uh so submit you can send me your
favorite clip it's very easy to clip on
YouTube make a little clip submit it uh
we announced this at the end of the week
you can also send in voicemails on our
Discord I threaten it all the time we're
collecting a cornucopia of voicemails
and one day we will unleash them upon
you but yeah we want to get a good
little selection going we're gonna start
working into the show I'm gonna say you
rather than you no no no don't grab it I
was just talking about whatever you want
if you're still watching you haven't hit
that like button hit that like button ah
here we go all right all right let's
start honking out oh God on the TV show
we all have to hug out on the same TV no
everybody pick it up okay I'll go quick
and first
Family Matters canceled two seasons too
soon you should have gone 11 years
instead of nine what Myra did not get
justice justice for Myra oh glove Jaleel
White's character Stephen Q Urkel the
Hulk one Family Matters reboot sometime
soon
okay Jessica you can pick another topic
if you want
[Applause]
True Blood gets a bad rap
you didn't give in the pack win a chance
it did it went a little off the rails
you just need no further your
imagination
okay so I understand but let's talk
about the good parts a lot of good
casting these people were great and fun
I like that a little too much sex I'll
be honest I had to fast forward it
because
they should have stopped a little bit
after the second season or at least you
know stayed on a one track because it
was a little off the road
Mary Louise Parker
Hawk have girlfriend who remind him of
Mary Louise Parker around a time that
weeds was coming out both looked very
good naked both emotionally unavailable
to Hulk Hulk cry and episodes of weeds
Hulk disappointed by later Seasons I
think it went off the rails afterwards
oh disappointed by end of relationship
Hulk Miss Mary Louise Parker Hulk do not
miss ex-girlfriend oh that's good Hulk
that's good good for you hope
don't think rehearsal most
groundbreaking television show ever
it doesn't matter if Hulk understand it
or not Hulk just glad television Taking
Chances sometime Hulk talking to you
Warner Brothers Discovery hoax they
don't cancel rehearsal let things be
weird on TV things are different Uncle
Hulk think Angela actress and Hulk being
played but Hulk doesn't mind Hulk loves
constant heightening on show also Hulk
doesn't understand why Hulk's wife
doesn't like that but they may called
watch never have I ever don't care Hulk
like never have I ever but after
watching rehearsal random Punk fight
never have I ever
formulated sometimes a little redundant
yeah some book Hulk's expectations
sunflute books expectations
my internet
[Music]